an erotic enthusiast finds his access to
porn isn't as mobile as he'd like so he
ponders that 21st century question is
there an app for that a dubious message
from the FBI appears suspicious files
have been found on his phone he's
accessed forbidden porn sites a penalty
of five hundred dollars is demanded he's
told that if he makes any attempt to
unlock the device on his own it's
against the law but he's done nothing
wrong he's just the victim of a new and
improved version of an insidious old
attack ransomware ransomware is malware
that locks your keyboard your computer
or your phone or encrypt your data that
is until you pay a ransom usually in
Bitcoin in 2012 Symantec gained access
to a server used by one piece of
ransomware called crypto details after
getting a glimpse at the hackers Hall
over just a single day Symantec
estimated but five million dollars is
likely extorted from victims each year
ransomware began in Russia and other
parts of Eastern Europe more than a
decade ago since then it's become
increasingly professionalized two years
ago a new tool arrived cryptolocker
cryptolocker is highly sophisticated
ransomware which uses public and private
cryptographic keys to lock and unlock
the victims files cryptolocker sometime
spreads via an email purporting to come
from UPS or FedEx victims are warned
that if they don't pay within four days
the decryption key will be destroyed and
no one will be able to unlock their
files today dozens of variants including
cryptolocker still proudly internet no
one is safe from an attack even law
enforcement agents have been ensnared
antivirus can help detect some attempts
to infect you with ransomware but not
all best defense against ransomware is
to regularly backup your files to an
external device and of course be careful
where you click